s'il n'y avait pas plus de cette
formation c'est que on s'est retrouvé
les professionnels son terrain à
discuter d'un sujet qui était je dirais
pas tabou des lilas lutter contre la
radicalisation si le sujet dont il est
question
jeudi 10 mars avait lieu à la préfecture
des yvelines la journée de restitution
du projet de formation sensibilisation
sur la manipulation mentale et l'emprise
psychologique lancée après les attentats
de janvier 2015
un sujet en amont des questions de
citoyenneté et de laïcité mais
nécessaires pour garantir la liberté
d'esprit
ce qui nous a été décrit à chaque fois
c'était je ne reconnais plus ma fille
elle est partie c'est pas comme ça que
je les ai élevés une incompréhension
totale
donc on dit oui c'est un lavage de
cerveau ils ont été manipulés et comme
on entendait ce terme de manière
récurrente on s'est dit tiens on va
s'intéresser à ckoi la manipulation
mentale neuf journées de formations se
sont tenues entre décembre 2015 et
février 2016 sur les quartiers
prioritaires des yvelines elles ont
associé acteurs de terrain associations
et chercheurs l'objectif est dé de
travailler autour du cyber
endoctrinement comment déceler l'emprise
les causes de l'endoctrinement au
maintenir le dialogue avec un jeune
radicaliser une réflexion appuyée sur un
support pédagogique
olympio se sent pas les personnes qui
sont face de nous qui parle on parle des
personnes qui sont présentes à l'écran
et donc en fonction de ça et bien ils
finissent par parler d'eux mêmes et de
leurs pratiques
mais sous couvert d'une tierce personne
à partir du moment où les idées sont
énoncées par la salle et non pas par la
personne qui est censé faire
le débat ça a beaucoup plus d'impact le
bilan est positif ces journées ont
permis de créer du dialogue entre les
différents acteurs de terrain et de
déterminer pour chaque territoire les
actions prioritaires à mettre en place
j'ai des gens qui avaient leur et qu'ils
ne comprenaient pas y a pas un seul
concerne pas que les rues des quartiers
pour compléter la formation des journées
de travail autour des thèmes de la
laïcité et des valeurs de la république
pour renforcer le lien social sont
prévues dans chacun de ces quartiers
prioritaires